its value is 8 times the sum of the
digit and
Oh goodbye its digits our wolf okay
that's a mouthful alright I barely
understand that okay so let's have a
look at it slowly together well unpack
it bit by bit right and by the way
that's a really important skill you're
in that previous question it's like a
whole paragraph one of the skills that
we use
yeah like looking for the important
details and like breaking into small
chunks so let's break this into small
chunks
you got an integer I've written it's
between ten and a hundred I'm just queen
n integers means a whole number so it's
not ten and a half it's like eleven its
value is eight times the sum of its
digits huh okay so if we had a number
like say 31 okay I can give these two
digits I can give them printing rules
right but you'll be careful because if I
call this one a and this one B right so
a is three and B is one right this
number you can't really write it as a B
can you write it's good yeah you're
going to dress it I'll wait for you to
sit and then it's fine silence again I'm
gonna cut this out okay yeah the last
one all right so if I want to write 31 I
can't write a B that's not 31 yeah
exactly we use that to mean a multiplied
by B but I can still write 31 I would
write it as like this is a place value
right that 3 doesn't really mean 3 it
actually means 3 lots of 10 right so
right and if I had like another digit
here that would be not fired but 5 lots
of 100 yeah so I can write 31 like this
I can say it's 10 a plus B 3 times 10
plus the 1 all right so let's call this
number a B right it is two digits so
it's because if it's a ten and a hundred
right so this number is 10 a plus B
where a is the tens digit
and the beers the units okay now what
are they tell us about this number it
says let's see its value is 8 times
everything's flowing down its value is 8
times the sum of its digits what is the
sum of these two digits it's just a plus
B right so the value 10 a plus B is 8
times the sum of the digits
do you see how I just said that there is
the actual number and there is 8 times
the sum of its digits okay
that's an equation we might as well are
we can simplify this now right this is a
a plus 8 B right
I can subtract 8 a from both sides which
gives me 2 a and I can subtract a B from
both sides which gives me 7 beep okay
let's just call that equation one and
then the other thing they tell us is if
it's digits are reversed its reduced by
45 so to reverse the digits is to swap
the tens and the units right
now B plus 10a is still gonna be equal
to the same thing as it's right so
actually I need to switch the B MEA
themselves so to be yet 1010 B plus a so
I've just switched the digits and that's
the same as taking the original number
and reducing it by what to say 45 okay
let's just make sure we understand what
we just did right this is me swapping
the digits right this is me looking at
the original but and subtracting
reducing it by 45
well maybe right well let's see what
happens I can simplify this just like I
simplified this one right let's see here
I can subtract a an A and a B from both
sides that would leave we with 9 B over
here and then over here it would leave
me with 9 a minus 45 can we simplify
this even further common factor what can
you divide through by 9 that'll leave me
with B
now that good so this guy I'm going to
call to what method of solution do you
think is the most helpful to put these
two together substitution is much easier
than elimination right so that's right I
can just squeeze it in here I'm gonna
substitute 2 into 1 can you tell me what
to write
very good that's the substitution you're
done equals to a so can you explain for
me Alex well yeah it applies to both
equal to it very good now what okay so I
should subtract away from both sides I
might as well add 35 to both sides also
okay good so what should be equal
apparently 7 minus 5 which is 2 let's
check this out apparently my number is
72 does it fit the conditions it is
between 10 100 if I add the digits
together I get 9 and so 9 times 8 this
number is 8 times the product of its
digits right it's 8 times 9 and then
what's the other thing if I reverse the
digits right is that equal to 45
I think it is right